ANGLE."
I AM JASON IN FOR LAURA
INGRAHAM.
WE HEARD A LOT ABOUT SPECIAL
PROSECUTORS AND INDEPENDENT
GENERAL WHO PLAY A HUGE AND
CRITTAL IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE
OVERSIGHT OF YOUR GOVERNMENT.
THERE ARE 72 AND THEY HAVE AN
ENORMOUS OF
ENORMOUS OF 13,500EMPLOYEES.
JOINING ME IS INSPECTOR GENERAL.
I WANT TO THANK YOU.
THE COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE.
PEOPLE THINK WE NEED A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR FOR THE FBI AND THE
DEPARTMENTS.
THEY ARE AUDITORS.
WHAT CAN THEY LOOK AT AND NOT
LOOK AT AND WHAT DO WE EXPECT
THE PEOPLE TO DO ON A DAILY
BASIS?
>> OUR JOB IS OVERSIGHT OF THE
WE CONDUCT AUDITS, INSPECTIONS,
REVIEWS AND CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR FRAUD, WASTE,
ABUSE AND INEFFICIENCY.
WE NEED THOSE DOCUMENTS?
DO THEY HAVE TO GIVE THEM TO US?
>> YES AND THEY DO.
>> ONCE THEY LEAVE AND DEPART,
YOU DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO
GET THAT INFORMATION.
>> WE CAN STILL SUBPOENA THEM
FOR DOCUMENTS.
WE SUBPOENA A FORMER EMPLOYEE TO
TALK TO US.
>> JUST TO GIVE VIEWERS AT HOME,
YOU GO TO THE WEBSITE.
IT YOU GO@ OVERSIGHT.GOV.
THAT'S THE TWITTER HANDLE.
4.2-BILLION DOLLARS IMPACT.
LOOKING AT THE VA.
WE ALL CARE ABOUT VETERANS WHO
SERVED THIS NATION.
IT SEEMS LIKE A DISASTER AND A
MESS.
WHERE IS IT TODAY?
>> WE ARE WORKING HARD TO FIX
WHISTLE BLOWERS.
>> WHAT IS NOT WORKING WELL AT
THE VA TODAY?
BILLS HAVE BEEN PASSED.
TODAY AS THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
WHAT IS YOUR BIGGEST CONCERN AT
THE VA?
>> JUST MAKING SURE THE PROMISE
WORK AND THE MONEY IS SPENT AS
RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE ARE ALWAYS FINDING OTHER
THINGS.
WE LOOK HARD AND WE HAVE A PROUD
STAFF THAT WORKS EVERY DAY TO
HELP MAKE THE PROGRAMS AND
OPERATIONS BETTER FOR VETERANS.
>> WE TALK ABOUT WANTING TO ROOT
OUT THE WASTE, FRAUD AND ABUSE.
HOW BIG OF THAT?
>> IT'S EXTREMELY LARGE.
>> HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS,
DOLLARS.
OUR ECONOMIC IMPACT WAS OVER $6
BILLION.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO
KNOW ABOUT THE INSPECTORS
GENERAL.
DO YOU NEED A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
IF YOU HAVE AN INSPECTOR GENERAL
DOING THEIR JOB?
>> ONE OF THE DIFFERENT FEATURES
ABOUT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS
OUR INDEPENDENCE.
WE DON'T REPORT TO ANYBODY.
WE DON'T REPORT TO THE HEAD OF
THE AGENCY.
THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE.
IT AA -- ALLOWS US TO GET THINGS
RIGHT.
>> I ALLOWED ON THE INSPECTOR
INFORMATION AND DOESN'T GET
IMPLEMENTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION OR THE CONGRESS
FORGETS ABOUT IT.